there was another national student
walkout today from school to protest gun
violence and this one was timed to
coincide with the 19th anniversary it's
hard to believe the shootings at
Columbine High School in Colorado
joining us now to discuss how to really
make schools safer is Daryl Scott
Darrell is the father of Rachel Scott
who was the first victim of the
Columbine high school shooters in
Littleton Colorado Darrel it's so great
to talk to you we have so many friends
in common and I'm so bowled over by
everything you've done in these last 19
years I'm sure to you it seems like
yesterday and you run this foundation
called Rachael's challenge tell us how
you think it's the best way to proceed
to actually stop these school shootings
well thank you Laura it's great to be
here with you I really want to applaud
young people for wanting to make a
difference and for for marching for what
they believe in I want to just gently
challenge them to focus on more than
just gun control because Eric and Dylan
the shooters at Columbine 19 years ago
said in a camera you're going to change
the gun laws you're going to add more
gun laws and it's not going to stop
people like us from doing what we do
and I'm as passionate about change as
these young people are in fact when the
cameras go away when the passion dies
down my challenge to all the young
people is to maintain their desire to
end the violence and our family has
chosen to do that over the last 19 years
we created a program for schools we
reach about one to two million students
each year over 25 million over the last
19 years and we've seen seven school
shootings prevented and we've seen an
average of about three suicides
prevented every week there's more far
more suicides than there are school
victims of school shootings and we've
done that through a message of kindness
compassion and helping connect people to
one another because when there's
violence or when there's reaction to
these kind of situations we can do one
of three things
can hate and we can retaliate dr. King
told us that hate will not remove hate
only love can do that so we can hate and
retaliate we can debate and demonstrate
or we can relate and communicate and
relating and communicating is what our
message has been and we see the fruit of
that I want to play for our viewers a
description of Rachel's writing your
daughter's writing let's listen she
understood the power that a simple act
of kindness can have I have the theory
that if one person can go out of their
way to show compassion then it will
start a chain reaction of the same you
know at a time when most kids in high
school are just trying to fit in she
just wanted to be herself and encouraged
others to do the same now I imagine
although it's hard to imagine there
probably isn't a 15 minute period of
five minute period over the last 19
years where you didn't think about your
daughter that's right and you know
there's a lot of a lot of attention
being poured a lot of money is being
poured into the gun issue and I'm not
here to debate that there there's money
from both sides of being poured into
that as a solution but we need to look
beyond the instrument and look at how we
can prevent these things from happening
starting with the hearts of our kids and
I want to challenge people to pour as
much money into programs like Sandy Hook
promise like kickstart for kids like why
try and like Rachel's challenge we have
a friend Foster Friess who has put up a
two and a half million dollars now
through the end of July and every one of
you who donate five dollars ten dollars
it's going to be doubled to Rachel's
Challenge you can go to Rachel Scott org
or Rachel Scott comm and it's going to
help us reach a lot more kids Darryl
this is so it this is a perfect way to
end this week something incredibly
positive incredibly compassionate and
real person touching person it's not
through a screen it's people helping
people one-on-one you got to reach out
to people who are in trouble and you've
done
that for the past 19 years you've turned
tragedy into triumph we pray for you and
for all the victims of gun violence and
tragedy across this country thank you
for what you're doing we need a
spiritual reawakening in this country
and you're helping along with Foster
Friess and so many others and you got a
donation coming from me my friend